>> So, hi everybody.
I'm going to present
our conversation in
a breakout session with
Don Bosco Youth at Risk
and Homelink Network NGO,
which basically work at
the forefront of finding
missing children in India.
As was presented yesterday,
missing children
are a big problem,
that there's a lot of runaway and
lost children on the street.
Don Bosco and Homelink
are at the forefront
of the fight of
trying to help them.
In particular, just the
Don Bosco organization
by themselves,
over the last 10 years,
have found almost 300,000
children on the streets,
and tried to help them by
finding their parents,
and if they don't manage
to find their parents,
and if they're placed
with them then actually
take taking care of
them in the long term.
So, out of those almost
300k missing children,
they have actually
successfully managed to find
the parents of 170,000 children,
which is a huge impact in
basically reuniting these kids
with their parents and
having a normal life.
So, how do they do their work?
Essentially, Homelink
has this front liners,
which are people going
to the train stations,
the bus stations, the markets,
likely locations where
children can get
lost or hangout if
they are runaways,
and they're looking out
essentially for kids
that look like they
don't have an adult with
them and approach them
and talk to them,
trying to identify
whether they need help.
Once they encounter a lost child,
they interview them in
the beginning because
of moderation,
they might give
very limited information,
and these primary initial
information is
related to social
workers that are in
the office are trying then to use
that limited key information
to quickly find the parents.
With that information,
essentially,
what they do is they
do Google searches
about like school names,
other landmarks that
they might mention,
or a village name, etc.
Then from there, if
they find anything
called the Local
Police Department,
try to see whether there's
a missing person report, etc.
So, it's a very
time intensive and
very kind of detective work,
so to say, with very extremely
limited information.
So, in particular,
one important thing is
basically being able to
match a kid back to
their parents if their loss is
extremely important
for their quality
of life and long-term effects.
Essentially, also even
the time that it
takes to match them
is also important.
So the longer time that
they spend in the system,
the bigger impact that has
like psychological
and emotionally
on the child in the long run.
So, our goal is can we
help our Don Bosco and
Homelink to maximize
the matches and
minimize the time in which
they manage to do that.
So, we identified
three particular areas
in which AI can help.
The first one was using
historic data in order to
identify key child information
that facilitates matches.
So, as they have a lot
of historic data,
what combinations
of key pieces of
information increase
the likelihood of a match?
The second one is can we use
historic data in order to
predict hotspots
in space and time,
so that they can allocate more
of those front liners to be at
the right places given
the very limited resources
that they have.
Finally, a more
long-term suggestion
is how can we create
a Missing Child Complaints
submission system?
Right now, there is really
no unified system like that.
It was mentioned, a lot
of people don't feel
comfortable going to the police
and even if they do,
the police don't
have a system that's
accessible by the NGOs.
So, can we create something
for the parents to report
their missing children that's
accessible and inclusive and
most people will feel
comfortable using.
So, on the first point.
So, again, here using
the historic data, as we said,
is almost 300k kids that were
actually found for which
they have this process of
the information that
they got whether
they managed to match
the parents or not.
We want to essentially build
a predictive model that
tells us which subsets,
which combinations of
features like age,
clothing, maybe village name,
or school name,
which of those things together
were the most effective
in creating a successful search.
So, as they're doing this,
they're actually interviewing
the kids over time.
So, there's even like
the sequential effect
where they will ask
more questions.
So, with this predictive model,
what we can do is we can use it
to give guideline
to the interviewer.
So, what questions to
ask like if they got,
for example, the village name,
what the other extra question
should they insist
on in order to most effectively
triangulate the parents.
So, maybe village name and xyz
together is much
more effective than
village name and other things
that they might ask.
So, the second one are also,
as I already mentioned,
there's very limited resources.
There's actually
a lot of variation
in the number of missing children
that are likely to be
at any particular time
in any particular place in time.
For example, there's
a seasonal variations,
there's holidays that intensify
the number of lost children,
and there's the local festivals
for related to particular places.
So, can we just mind
this rich historic
dataset to map where
these hotspots are and
help them allocate
strategically
their resource occasion.
We believe that this
is something that is
very quite easy to do.
So, that would be our first
data exploration exploiting
the readily available
and low hanging fruit
in a blank and blank AI.
Then, the one that I mentioned
before is going to be
our second thing that we'll try.
In the longer term,
we're going to try to create
this Missing Child Complaints
submission system that,
again, has to be
accessible and inclusive,
that many parents who have
low literacy and that are not
using the Internet to go and
create an online profile
for their kids.
There's also
many languages in India.
So, from that perspective,
we came up with two things.
First of all, there should be
some way of them just
leaving a voice message,
and in that case we can use AI to
translate whatever local
language they're using to
English and transcribe
it and then pass it into
an actual child record it is
searchable when a child is found.
Additionally, if
the parents are able,
they can upload an image
or send a text message with
an image of their child,
and then we can use AI
to match the parent
submitted photos to photos of
the children found by the NGO.
As I mentioned, there's
already a lot of
additional available data
over 10 years,
almost 300,000 missing children
found by Don Bosco and Homelink.
They already have the data
with the time the others was
found and the key pieces
of information
that were gathered for
each child like gender,
age, clothing details, etc.
So, we're going to use this data
in our first two tasks.
Some of the ethical concerns in
the broader scope of
this operation that we
identified is if we're
trying to create some kind
of a system that works
across institutions,
how can we resolve into
institutional issues and
standardizations of
sharing the data in
order to be able to
facilitate this matching with
all of the data that's
available across
all the stakeholders and
players in this field?
There was some discussion
about using biometric data,
so with respect to
that we have to
worry about law compliance.
Finally, we want to make
sure that whatever we do,
we want to secure the data
from misuse by traffickers.
So, thank you.